figaro live bonjour à toutes et à tous
bienvenue pour ce nouveau direct il est
14h22 letang 8 minutes environ les
obsèques de christophe dominici vont
débuter dans l'église que vous apercevez
sur ces images l'église san louis on est
à hyères dans le var on est à quelques
kilomètres de toulon l'un des clubs
justement ou à jouer
christophe dominici qu'on a retrouvé
mort sans vie le mardi 24 novembre dans
le parc de saint cloud près de paris
on va suivre ça on va voir qui arrive en
direct et bien dans cet édifice
religieux on est avec david reyrat
bonjour david chef de service à sport24
sport 24 points lefigaro.fr vous
connaissez l'adresse évidemment si vous
êtes fidèle de notre rubrique sport et
vous êtes responsable plus
particulièrement de la section rugby
david vous avez bien sûr écrit bien
beaucoup d'articles depuis qu'on a
appris cette terrible nouvelle il y a
une dizaine de jours maintenant on a
beaucoup parlé de l'émotion au sein des
joueurs et des anciens joueurs mais
j'imagine que chez les journalistes de
sport et en particulier les spécialistes
rugby ça dû être là stupéfaction qu'on a
appris cette nouvelle
c'était un gros choc pour mes confrères
et moi même
et l'autre plusieurs en avoir discuté
voilà ça fait très longtemps que je
fourre trop longtemps peut-être que je
couche de rugby pour le figaro j'ai
commencé en 1996 donc que j'étais très
proche de l'équipe du stade français à
partir des années 90 à 98 aller du
premier titre la relance du club par max
guazzini et j'ai eu beaucoup côtoyé et
christophe dominici à l'époque donc
lycée c'était un choc pour beaucoup de
monde même en dehors des sportifs et
genlis j'ai vu aussi que par exemple
jean michel blanquer revêt avait rendu
un hommage le soir même à l'assemblée
nationale et que les députés s'étaient
s'était levé pour applaudir la mémoire
de joueur français alors il ya déjà eu
une première messe cette semaine en
l'honneur des motions avec beaucoup
d'émotion c'était à boulogne billancourt
en région parisienne là tout près du
parc de saint cloud on a vu des images
très fortes mais parce que comme c'était
à bougnol c'est juste à côté du club du
stade français il allait voler pendant
pendant 14 saisons il a gagné cinq
titres de champion de france et y avait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de ces de ses
coéquipiers de l'époque y avait aussi
évidemment de max guazzini son président
et bernard laporte qui l'a entraînée qui
a faim pour lequel et avec lequel il
était très proche et beaucoup beaucoup
de joueurs ce qu'il appelait ses frères
d'armes s'est d'ailleurs certains c'est
eux ce sont certains d'entre eux qui ont
qui portait mercredi dernier son son
cercueil blanc et c'est vincent moscato
christophe moni front de combat et
sylvain marconnet quatre joueurs du
stade français qui a évolué pendant une
dizaine d'années alors on va rester sur
ces images on va vous permettre de les
vivre en direct tout le temps les
commentant vous apercevez bien le
cortège qui est en train d'arriver on a
aperçu il ya quelques instants devant
l'édifice des portraits de christophe
dominici il ya plusieurs portraits 4 me
semble-t-il
alors ce qui frappe quand même ce qui
m'a frappé c'est que sur tous ces
portraits on le voit avec le maillot de
l'équipe de france on ne voit pas que le
maillot de toulon alors qu'on est à
quelques kilomètres de toulon c'est
surprenant
toulon c'est le début de sa carrière il
il faut retracer sa y laisser un enfant
de toulon de solliès-pont il a débuté et
là bas il a fait ses quatre premières
années là bas mais un jour de 97
l'époque le club de le rugby club
toulonnais ne n'étais pas en haut de la
fiche comme aujourd'hui est un jour de
cette action son ami son ami le plus
proche notre joueur franck combat qui
était comme lui un tout petit qui est
comme lui un tout petit gabarit disent
ils en ont marre de rester à toulon où
ça gagne pas ou le club va sans doute
descendre il n'y a pas d'ambition n'y a
pas de projet et décide de tenter le
coup ils savent qu'un que max guazzini
en train de monter une nouvelle aventure
à paris avec le stade français est un
jour sur un coup de tête ils décident
tous les deux d'aller comme ça à
l'audace d'aller voir max guazini le
rendez vous se passe pas très bien parce
que c'est sur les propos motrice au
domicile il nous a vus arriver habillés
en cagoule toulonnaise avec chemise
ouverte avec la dent de requin autour du
cou etc
l'entretien s'est pas très bien passé
mais heureusement pour eux d'aider
proche de max ont plaidé leur cause et
ils ont été recrutés et pourquoi on
parle plus de stade français où l'équipe
de france est parce que là tout le monde
il a joué quatre saisons sans rien
gagner alors que stade français qui a
passé 14 saisons avec cinq titres de
champion de france de finale de coupe
d'europe
et pour revenir sur la photo avec le
maillot de l'équipe de france c'est
parce que hélas aussi christophe le
disait régulièrement il était un joueur
quelconque il est devenu un grand joueur
un joueur médiatique à joueur populaire
anp le 31 octobre 1999 lors de la demi
finale de la coupe du monde de rugby
entre la france et les all blacks jonah
lomu personne ne pariez sur une victoire
du quinze de france est là lui miracle
est arrivé et c'est écrit sur du mi6 qui
avait initié la révolte avec un
magnifique essai en 2000
en début de seconde mi-temps qui avait
lancé les bleus vers sète cette victoire
improbable et cet exploit majuscule du
sport français
un message de virginie sur youtube on
est aussi sur lefigaro.fr bonjour à
toutes et à tous j'arrive toujours pas à
y croire domino a quitté c'est une
terrible perte toutes mes condoléances à
sa famille justement on va
vous faire remonter l'ambiance pour vous
faire vivre et bien ce qui est en train
de se passer devant cette église saint
louis à hyères dans le var à quelques
kilomètres de toulon le cortège
funéraire qui vient d'arriver
on s'est aussi réuni la famille à
demander en toute intimité donc c'est
pour ça qu'il n'y a pas non plus vous le
dis le nombre a baissé il y aura moins
de monde que mercredi à boulogne il ya
plusieurs couronnes de fleurs qui ont
été envoyés notamment par nicolas
sarkozy et carla bruni
voilà d'ailleurs vous les voyez c'est
ses fleurs qui sont en forme de coeur
ses couronnes là qui sont en train
d'être descendu et bien des véhicules
qui sont devant cette église saint louis
il y a les clubs de rugby locaux dont
celui de solliès-pont dont vous avez
parlé il ya quelques instants david
reyrat d'ailleurs j'ai vu une anecdote
je sais pas si vous l'avez vu également
alors apparemment il a commencé le
football au football et parce que son
père joue au football à un bon niveau un
papa professionnelle mais un bon niveau
régional et il allait naturellement
suivi les traces de son père est en fait
un jour un match de foot contre la
valette si on connaît la cotation du
coin c'est un club un peu un peu de
méchant ça se passe mal christophe qui a
un tempérament bouillant et sanguins
comme d'habitude déclenché déclenché une
bagarre alors pas dire autre chose et là
il se retrouve surpris parce qu'il est
seul
aucun de ses coéquipiers de l'équipe de
foot ne vient et donc ce jour là ce soir
là il rentre chez lui il dit je change
de sport
moi je veux un sport on est tous
solidaires et il est allé ensuite
puisque il aimait bien avec son
caractère sanguin qui voit là si on
connaît son histoire personnelle il est
d y vivaient des choses un peu
compliquées
à cette époque là donc ils étaient un
peu bagarreur et il est ensuite passé au
club de rugby local et là ça s'est
beaucoup mieux passé pour lui je viens
d'apercevoir quand même là les premières
personnes on voit hubert falco le maire
de toulon vannes moizini à sa gauche le
président du stade français est derrière
bernard laporte le président de la
fédération française de rugby qui fut je
rappelle donc que son entraîneur au
stade français est ensuite surtout son
sélectionneur pendant huit ans la tête
du quinze de france
oui bernard laporte on l'aperçoit il est
vraiment au pied de la porte
c'est le cas de le dire il est devant
l'entrée en haut à droite si voilà si
les images restent reste abidal eux le
masque aux couleurs me semble-t-il à la
fédération de la fédération alors
de france on reconnaît les couleurs du
maillot de l'équipe de france 67
sélections 25 et ses 25 essais c'est
beaucoup beaucoup en route la bonne
moyenne mais il sait pas c'est pas le
maximum mais fait partie du top 5 des
marqueurs d'essai en équipe de france
ah oui c'est une belle performance ils
ont fui comme je vous disais là la
gauche demain à la porte
c'est hubert falco donc le maire de
toulon est avec la capuche plus grand
encore gauche et max guazzini donc pas
oublier qu'ils étaient très proches
d'eux le christophe dans l'interview
qu'il nous a accordée difficilement
parce qu'il était en larmes juste après
juste après la disparition tragique de
christophe nous a rappelé on le savait
mais nous a rappelé que c'était son
joueur préféré qu'ils avaient une
relation particulière tous les deux
c'est à dire que dès que christophe
allait mal parce que voilà il avait des
épisodes de dépression et que christophe
a du mal il l'appeler max les bergers il
pouvait passer une journée nuit dix
jours quinze jours chez lui avec max qui
veillait à lui remonter le moral
on
sa compagne sont sa femme s'est arrimé
loretta paris match
en réfutant la thèse du suicide qui
semble privilégiée par les enquêteurs
non alors là il ya aucune thèse
privilégiée justement les provinces de
l'enquète ne permettent pas de dire si
c'était délibéré ou ou accidentel s'est
a priori n'arriveront pas à conclure
puisque le seul témoin oculaire un
cycliste qui passait par là a bien vu
christophe basculer mais il a affirmé
aux enquêteurs qu'il n'avait pas vu
enfin qu'il n'était jamais monté sur le
parapet la vue d'un coup subitement
basculé sur la droite passer par dessus
le petit parce que c'est un tout petit
parapet est tombé d'une quinzaine de
mètres et donc les enquêteurs le premier
enfant en tout cas le premier les
éléments de l'enquète d'excusés pour
l'instant ce n'était pas possible de
conclure à une chute volontaire ou
accidentel et oui ils sont sa veuve
affirme elle que christophe ne vais pas
vous n'avez pas de envie d'en finir avec
la vie un seul témoin lors du drame et
qui n'a pas été interrogé tout de suite
puisqu'il était en état de choc on était
près de l'autoroute a13 ont ce parc de
saint cloud là on est devant l'église
saint louis à hyères vous êtes toujours
ex no1 sur lefigaro.fr et sur notre
chaîne youtube on est avec david reyrat
chef de service à à sport24 spécialistes
rugby un pur et bien vivre ensemble
c'est arrivé à l'église saint louis à
hier donc le cercueil de christophe
dominici qui va sortir est ressorti être
transporté à l'intérieur
mesdames messieurs nous sommes justement
rassemblés cet après midi sur le parvis
de l'église samedi à hier accompagné
monsieur dominici les scores oui il y
aura un gros navire aux marques avant de
pénétrer au sein de l'église le père
christian à nous accueillir pour la
messe je vous remercie
[Musique]
1 quels qu'ils soient que des fois
accueilli dans ta lumière et dante
appelle les soutiens à nous par la force
de leur présence les fournaises tu sois
notre le mans
vous
vous êtes toujours avec nous sur figaro
log le figaro.fr nationaux où tu
poursuis le cinquième l'an les
applaudissements david reyrat sait
vraiment où on en voit presque tous les
jours on entend presque tous les jours
depuis ce drame et rencontres de top 14
les all-blacks voici qui ont publié mais
c'est un message assez émouvant petit
par la taille mais j'en ignore le temps
immense par le talent oui mais les
dominici avait marqué voilà on joue pas
98 à 2007 donc pendant presque dix ans
en équipe de france sans se faire
remarquer par ses adversaires et en plus
les all blacks qui les a battus à deux
reprises
olaf heyden ici juste pour donner un
exemple de sa carrière internationale
premier match en février 98 première
sélection face à l'angleterre
les premières sélections premier essai
victoire de la france donc sa carrière
avait démontré sur les sur les chapeaux
de roue et comme on dit tout à l'heure
25 essais en 67 sélections c'est c'est
un très très bon ratio
après il ya aussi l'anecdote on va
essayer d'en mettre un petit sourire
quelques secondes en 2004 il est aussi
quelque chose qui les met pas vraiment
qu'on lui rappelle le fameux match
contre l'italie christo celui ci a passé
toute la défense et il arrive en courant
tranquillement dans l'en but et puis là
il fait un peu le malin et il lâche le
ballon avant d'aplatir ce qui avait valu
une énorme colère malgré la victoire me
met en colère de 20 à la porte c'est à
dire que ces jours là il a raté son 26e
essai il avait vu juste et aplatir mais
il là il a fait le malin et voilà c'est
une histoire qui l'aimé pas trop qu'on
lui rappelle je vais faire quelques
messages que vous postez sur notre
chaîne youtube notamment des messages
d'hommage vous
si elodie rip pascal salut champion on
gardera de toit l'ensemble de ta
carrière que de beaux souvenirs malgré
l'émotion qui nous gagne aujourd'hui
yann toutes mes condoléances à la
famille et aux proches
ado me repose en paix nous dit nathan
florence adieu l'artiste et merci laurie
repose en paix christophe dominici
continuer si vous avez des messages
d'hommage à christophe dominici vous
avez dit tout à l'heure david david
reyrat qui est avec nous de sport24 pour
pour commenter vous avez dit première
sélection premier essai est-ce que ça à
la sq et la même émotion la même valeur
que un premier but sur une première
sélection en équipe de france de foot
par exemple sur mesure et surtout
c'était face à l'angleterre
c'est à dire que il ya deux matches qui
sortent du lot pour l'équipe de france
c'est quand elle affronte les all blacks
parce que c'est la meilleure équipe du
monde et toute la mythologie qu'il ya
autour de ses joueurs néo zélandais est
ensuite bien sûr c'est le fameux crunch
le le match qu'ils ont tendance de dire
le match contre nos meilleurs ennemis
donc un france angleterre il n'y a pas
mieux pour pour se faire remarquer et
lui comme aux commandites à leur
première sélection premier c'est contre
les anglais il ya un an plus tard il
éclate à la face de la planète ovale en
en enclenchant la révolte française face
aux all blacks en demi-finale de la
coupe du monde 99
donc c'est de ces deux premiers exploits
sont face aux deux équipes les plus
réputées du concert international donc
ça évidemment aidé à sa popularité
cinq titres de champion avec le stade
français vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure david quatre fois je crois qu'on
l'a pas mentionné mais quatre fois le
tournoi des six nations dont 2 grand
chelem dont 2 grand chelem et oui on
veut dire si la danse qui négligent
tournoi et il en a gagné 4 et a là aussi
encore un fameux ratio quand même et
puis finaliste du mondial 99 et il faut
le rappeler
dominati a participé à trois coupes du
monde d'ailleurs il a fait ensuite à
cause du monde 2003 comme titulaire et
2007 en france où il commençait dès 10
ans puisqu'il allait prendre sa retraite
une année plus tard où il était plutôt
remplaçant mais enfin quand je jouais
des bouts de matchs qu'il a participé à
trois coupes du monde
voyez ce portrait dominici le maillot de
l'équipe de france
toutes ses couronnes de fleurs qui sont
devant l'église saint louis à hier hier
c c'est chez lui oui c'est chez lui
c'est sait où le cimetière où le le
caveau familial tout à l'heure il
reposera au cimetière de la ritorte tout
à fait tout à l'heure il reposera à côté
de sa soeur aînée pascal qui explique
voilà toutes ses fragilités dont on a
parlé tout tout tout c'est ce mal être
sa soeur qui est décédé dans un accident
de voiture en 1986 quand il avait 14 et
14 ans l'un des dix de plus l'histoire
c'est que c'est lui qui raconte dans sa
biographie sortie en 2007 bleus à l'âme
c'est que ses parents travailler
beaucoup donc il disait que c'était sa
deuxième maman c'est elle qui lui
faisait les devoirs qui s'occupait de
lui
voilà c'était pas d'autres termes que
celui qu'il a donné que c'était sa
deuxième maman et donc sa disparition
l'avait vraiment vraiment éprouvé et
papa cas pas cas c'est pas là puisque il
avait régulièrement ddd souvient un peu
noir de ce décès ces disparitions ont
on voit les entrées dans cet édifice
quelques survêtement
du rct à toulon on n'a pas perçu mourad
boudjellal
en revanche l'ancien président j'ai
aperçu au hasard là où on voit philippe
guillard l'ancien joueur du racing qui a
été également longtemps chroniqueur
[Musique]
chroniqueur sur canal + équivalent
réalisateur de films c'est lui qui a
fait le fils à jo par exemple la la le
joueur au premier plan c'est benjamin
fall un joueur qui évolue à montpellier
avant et j'ai vu derrière daniel herrero
le goût amer aux quais avec le bandeau
rouge dans les cheveux
commentateur du rugby sur sud radio il
me semble en gt j'entends l'entraîneur
joueur et puis entraîneur du rc toulon
quelques commentaires encore sur
facebook
bonjour à vous léon qui est avec nous
que la méditerranée veille sur toi nous
dit nous dit ian a effectivement on a
parlé en état hier on apparaître toulon
d'appareils de solliès on est vraiment
chez chez christophe dominici
vous voyez c'est ce public les anonymes
et puis les personnalités plus les
personnalités qui sont en train de
pénétrer dans cette église saint louis
on apparaître bernard laporte tout à
l'heure on est de parler de daniel
herrero un david et puis tout à l'heure
max guazzini aussi max guazzini ancien
alors c'est sûr son premier vrai contrat
professionnel il le signe au stade
français n'ont-ils le synode toulon il
le signe à toulon on n'est ni s'est
plaint du y avait pas de résultats
toulon les qu'ils n'ont pas du salaire
mais du fait qu'il a manqué d'ambition à
l'époque y avait pas il n'y avait pas
dirigeants qui c'est qui a vu mettez les
moyens nécessaires pour que tout le
monde retrouve le haut de la fiche et
qui après quatre saisons à vivoter enfin
de division 1 et et sans jamais pouvoir
espérer mieux ou espérer un titre comme
visiteur il est décidé avec son ami
franck combat qui lui joué trois quarts
centre qu'ils avaient en commun tous
deux des petits gabarits à mettre 70
tous les deux de tenter l aventure
parisienne où max relancer un club
centenaire qui qui dès sa première année
déjà des 90 dès qu'il a retrouvé l'élite
a été sacré champion de france avait été
une histoire un peu fantastique
à l'époque quelques quelques messages ou
là alors repasser sur nos cadres au
revoir domi merci pour ce que tu nous a
fait vivre
tu nous a fait frémir en tant que
spectateur un joueur aux multiples
chevaucher un virevoltant fougueuse les
qualificatifs ne manquent pas un
finalement comment vous vous qualifiez
vous c'était ça il puisait une rage de
vaincre dans le fait que toulon 10e et a
vu son gabarit ne pourra pas rivaliser
avec les les joueurs de l'époque prendre
un exemple de la grande salle pas que
c'était jonah lomu qui pesait 50 kg de
plus que christophe dominici qui faisait
près de deux mètres et ils ont puisé une
rage pouvait que lui non avec son petit
gabarit pouvait réussir et c'est parce
que j'ai c'était qu'il était très rapide
qu'il avait des des appuis et des
crochets fenomeno est instantané et
surtout sur tout ce qui faisait sa force
à l'époque c'était cette capacité de
double accélération c'est à dire qu'il a
accéléré une première fois et quand les
joueurs pensaient qu'ils allaient le
rattraper il était il avait la capacité
physique de remettre une seconde
accélération pour faire la différence
tout tout sur la vitesse et la vivacité
beaucoup de sourires mais maintenant on
a plus d'imagés en direct mais on
diffuse une boucle des images fournies
par nos confrères de la fp de l' agence
france-presse
un joueur souriant affectif il était
commandant le vestiaire il était très
drôle était très drôle tout tout tout et
tous ses coéquipiers ont raconté déjà
évoque nous raconter maintenant que
c'était le c'était le boute-en-train
avoir un peu plus du vestiaire c'était
utilisez toujours en train de remettre
la bonne ambiance de de faire en sorte
que l'équipe vive bien et puis passer
son temps à faire affaire il a joué des
tours en particulier aux gros comme il
est remplacé les avants il est bien se
frotter aux avants le provoquer et
montré encore une fois qu'ils avaient
peur de rien quelques messages encore
sûr sur youtube jean-marc jean-marc
cousin bonjour repose en paix champion
adieu légende repose en paix c'est ce
que vous postez aussi
kevin dans les rugbymen français les
plus connus les plus performants le
place où domine ici dans le top 10 dans
le top 5 dans le top 3 top 3 vous n'êtes
pas parce qu'il ya comme des joueurs
phénoménaux comme serge blanco ou
philippe sella qui compte en tout cas
plus est à plus de 100 sélections il ya
aussi un fabien pelous chi chi le record
man des sélections et un thierry
dusautoir au pôle t on peut le mettre
dans le top 10 c'est certain ensuite il
faudrait affiner est ce qu'il est dans
le top cinq en tout cas il est pas loin
entre entre le top 5 et le top-10 usam
et c'est sûr fait partie du top 10 ou
adieu champions nous dit alex ans je
voyais aussi tiens bout de butch qui
nous écrit d'algérie
toutes mes condoléances à toute sa
famille au sport mondial c'est une
grosse perte pour le pour le rugby c'est
ce que c'est ce que vous nous dites bout
de jeu il était connu à l'international
dominici dans les pays de rugby 1 dans
les pays de rugby oui oui vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure les all blacks l'ont
aussitôt rendu hommage en angleterre il
était très connu dans les dents les
nations majeures du concert
international donc on va prendre les
destinations les équipes du six nations
c'est à dire l'angleterre les causes les
pays de galles l'irlande le frigo après
ensuite en afrique du sud en australie
en nouvelle zélande il était il était
très connue très réputé oui et puis je
pense que sa popularité dépasser le a
fini par l'excellent d'ovalie parce qu
on se souvient que quelques années après
sa retraite il avait participé à
l'émission de tf1 danse avec les stars
donc quand un joueur sort de son sport
pour partie qu'une émission comme ça
populaire de télévision c'est qu'il
dépassait un peu le simple domaine du
rugby et bien écoutez merci beaucoup un
david reyrat d'avoir commenter avec nous
bien c'est arrivé à l'église saint louis
de hyères dans le var où se déroule en
ce moment et bien les obsèques pour la
deuxième fois de la semaine finalement 1
2 de christophe dominici après boulogne
billancourt mercredi l'a cette fois on
est dans le terreau familial de le
berceau finalement de christophe
dominici qui sera dans le cercueil
prendra ensuite la la direction du
cimetière de la ritorte toujours dans
cette commune de hyères près de près de
toulon où se trouve dans ce cimetière le
caveau familial quelques messages avant
de se quitter
jean-yves rip champions nathalie un beau
gosse c'est triste si jeune le pauvre 48
ans 48 ans je ne sais plus si on l'a
rappelé depuis le début de soleil mais
effectivement 48 ans il y avait
ce projet un ce projet de rachat de
béziers porter c'était une portée cet
été qui a été un gros coup finalement
porté à son oral c'est ce que tous ses
proches ont dit c'est ce que sans sa
veuve a confirmé ce matin une interview
à paris match qu'il avait vraiment très
mal vécu cet échec parce que comme dans
tout ce qu'il faisait il faisait avec
conviction avec passion et avec la
certitude l envie de réussir et
finalement c'était un échec puisque le
repreneur qui l'avait contacté pour
représenter son dossier
un homme d'affaires franco tunisien
s'est révélé ensuite pas solvable pas la
hauteur des sommes qu'il avait promis
d'engager donc forcément ce feuilleton
qui avait duré cinq ou six semaines cet
été entre juin et juillet c'était
s'étaient conclues dans dans le refus
dans les chèques et ça s'était mal passé
parce que christophe a été
malheureusement l'objet de dépôts
bienveillant rayonnerait réseaux sociaux
qui s'était un peu moqué de lui qui voit
là et surtout il va pas sur tout mais
également il y avait une sortie au
vitriol du maire de béziers ont permis
nar qui l'avait qu'il avait vraiment
vilipendé pour cet échec avait
est accusé d'avoir vendu du rêve et
jamais de deux choses concrètes et tous
ses proches le disent nous l'ont dit
nous l'ont confié qu'il est très très
mal vécu cet échec que cet été j'avais
dû repasser une dizaine de jours en
clinique
suite à l'échec du projet de reprise
parce qu'il était retombé à tomber dans
un épisode de dépression donc voila et
son sa veuve leurs étals dinan paris
match et matin qu'il avait été dévastée
par par eux par cet épisode
merci pour ces précisions david je vois
françois oth qui nous dit sur
lefigaro.fr un grand champion il m'a
beaucoup marqué on a aussi un internaute
merci pour toutes ces émotions à david
c'est vrai beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup
d'émotions entre la fin des années 90 et
et ces années et ces années 2000 et puis
finalement il a il a accompagné la cc au
moment de sa carrière que s'est produite
la professionnalisation de ce sport est
aussi tout à fait le rugby devient
professionnel officiellement 1995 mais
pour des raisons pas évoqué l'âme et la
france elle a choisi parce qu'on était
pas vu le passif de passer professionnel
en 98 trois ans plus tard donc quand je
vous dis sa carrière a vraiment appris à
vraiment démarrer a vraiment pris son
ampleur dire de 97 non plus il fait
partie de la première génération en tout
cas les joueurs qui sont des joueurs
français qui sont passés professionnels
est-ce qu'on reste conseillée pour un
ordre d'idées qu'elle est quel salaire y
toucher dominici ou qu'elles étaient un
moyen des salaires au début de cette
professionnalisation ça dépendait des
clubs j'imagine et il met dans ces
années-là pas aujourd'hui oui bien sûr
les joueurs touchés
parler en francs évidemment l'enfant
mais j'ai pas eu le temps euros il
devait toucher dans les quinze mille
euros par mois merci en tout cas pour
tous vos messages je vois ça défile beau
coup sûr sur youtube je voyais qu'on
qualifiait christophe dominici de plus
grand rugbyman français et puis je
voyais aussi un message venu d'ollioules
on est là aussi dans le var à en parler
de la valette tout à l'heure on était
hier sur c'est sur ces images un ancien
rugbyman c'était alain qui salue et
dominici à alain ancien rugbyman
d'ollioules mais ressemble à votre
question oui il m'a battu vous me
demandez s'il était en toc droite au
sein que le dise je vois que j'en dise
que c'est le plus grand joueur ça dépend
si on se réfère si on se réfère sur ces
20 dernières années
si on oublie le passé les gens comme
jean pierre rives joueurs comme jean
pierre rives où serge blanco
on va dire depuis ces vingt dernières
années il est évidemment dans le top 3
et en ont peut on peut peut-être parce
que nos internautes parlent beaucoup de
l'émotion suscitée par dominici
peut-être que il fallait pas être
cardiaque quand vous voyez déchirure
c'est sûr ils réaliser les actions
imprévisibles c'est ça aussi c'est pour
ça qu'il a été
tentant émettant populaire c'est que
voilà il partait tout seul et il est
fier comme j'ai toujours les plus gros
il en passer l'an passé de l'an passé 3
avec ses crochets imprévisible et
insaisissable donc et comme on voit sur
la photo et sa petite soeur un petit peu
aussi moqueur ailleurs il avait la
gouaille la gouaille du minou toulonnais
est ce qu'il a vous dites un peu un peu
un peu malicieux et ce qu'il a fait ce
qu il faisait sortir de ses gonds un peu
ses adversaires parfois ou non non non
parce que c'est pas trop mon talent
était rugby c'est vrai qu'il faisait pas
ça mais mais mais ils communiquaient son
plaisir sa joie de vivre sa joie de
marquer sa joie de réussir un joli coup
voilà il partage était plus dans le
partage que dans le chambrage merci à
toutes et à tous de nous avoir suivi sur
lefigaro.fr et sur youtube vous êtes
nombreux à nous remercier d'avoir
diffusé ces images c'est il ya quelques
minutes on va se quitter avec cette
boucle d'imagés puis à tous les derniers
développements autour de la disparition
de christophe dominici sont à retrouver
bien évidemment sur sport24 pour le
figaro.fr vous pouvez retrouver aussi
l'interview que vous avez fait avec
arnaud coudry david de mourad boudjellal
avec cette semaine je salue stéphane je
salue sandrine jocelyne nathalie kevin
il ya alexandre mais l'hymne qui étaient
avec nous sur notre chaîne youtube
coucou aussi à françois qui nous a
suivis sur lefigaro.fr on va se quitter
sur ces images du regretté christophe
dominici et on vous souhaite à toutes et
à tous une excellente fin de journée est
d'ores et déjà un très bon week-end